during a campaign rally in Alabama last  night President Trump took aim at NFL  players who have refused to stand for  the national anthem the movement was  started last year by then San Francisco  49ers quarterback Colin Kaepernick who  was protesting police violence since  then other players have knelt or carried  out other reforms of Pro other forms of  protest during the anthem  the president said team owners should  get rid of those players wouldn't you  love to see one of these NFL owners when  somebody disrespects our flag to say get  that off the field right now out he's  fired this morning the head of the NFL  Players Association released a statement  saying the union will never back down  when it comes to players constitutional  rights it's a real hot spot around the  league yeah and you know surprised even  with Colin Kaepernick not playing that  the protests continue in the union  continues to back its players